hi I'm Joe Parisi I'm the studio and
audio director at infusion hi I'm Chris
I Solano and I'm the art director here
and we're going to give you a sneak peek
at space noir so let's get started our
game is about how Markham a bounty
hunter working off of books for the
galaxy's largest corporation syntax what
we're looking at here is his garage and
home in big city there's a lot to do
here but we're going to cover that
another time yeah so let's jump right
into the action what we're about to show
is a pre-alpha so a lot may change
orders work in progress we're always
trying to improve the game so a lot may
change for release mr. hammock sure this
is a side quest when we've been hired to
defend a black market dealers ship Depot
until he can defend it himself this is
more on the Leiter's action side and not
so much the heavier noir story elements
that are in the game which we haven't
really shown yet but that's not too far
if you look in the top left corner you
can see our comlink for the game our
comm link is where we display
information such as different characters
different story objectives or even just
pieces of the environment that we want
to show the player what are you talking
about where we are right now is on the
surface of our Ghana which is the Blues
or the snow planet of our game our game
has surface and space missions so we're
going to show you our surface mission
tonight yeah and what's really cool is
as you play through the game you will be
doing certain missions that will
actually change the environment and that
will continue to be around when you come
back and do later side quests and stuff
like that so it looks like we're almost
at our objective here that blue
exclamation mark in the distance and up
enemies you can see on screen right now
our radar cuts which is really our
answer to how to
lenz the whip the radars doing into the
game world so that we don't have to have
this UI cluttering the screen or
anything it really keeps the player
engaged in what he's doing yeah we have
these really huge environments and it
really helps to navigate you can see how
nimble the ship is we have it barrel
rolling doing 180s it's really important
for our game that not only you have
strong offensive abilities but really
strong defensive abilities as well we
want lots of evasive maneuvers and being
able to out maneuver your opponents as
opposed to just having stronger weapons
going along with our minimalist HUD that
we have for the game one of the really
cool features is that we actually
display the health of the player on his
ship which is those nice little red
pipes that are in the back and as the
player takes damage you can actually
watch those dream which is really cool
we also have a reticle that doubles as
your primary secondary and utility
display for information so each piece of
the reticle represents your blasters
your missiles or utility yeah and of
course we're just showing blasters and
missiles right now but there's an entire
arsenal you can equip you can equip two
weapons at any time plus a third utility
which will give you an example of a
little later and they are all fully
upgradeable and what's cool thing about
our upgrade system is it doesn't just
increase the stats once you get a weapon
or utility to a certain level a
basically a new version of it appears
like for the blasters you'll gain some
extra blasters and for the missiles you
can lock on to multiple enemies and fire
it at the same time so stuff like that
is really cool and it's not just weapons
and utilities you can upgrade your hull
your thrusters you don't change the
paint job all kinds of stuff you can do
detecting too large something that's
really important for us with our art
style was really pushing everything
over-the-top our explosions
if you made them and we liked him leave
making three times bigger our blast your
feedback is really big you get a lot of
feedback on our game and keep singing
bored excited yeah I really like the
wage I just don't see why squashes up
the mountains and different objects and
stuff it's awesome so it looks like some
new powerful enemies have appeared these
big guys over here they're not as easy
as the grunts you have to take out their
weak points so as we get close it's time
to whip out our utility and boom clothes
the turrets lose track of me and I can
attack at will without having to worry
about taking any more fire and totally
not the cloak wears off of course and
we've got a bunch of other utilities
that do other exciting things like that
one of the cool things about the game is
depending how you outfit your ship
before you enter into a mission it
totally changes how you would approach
handling certain enemies and situations
one of the things that was really
important to us when we started the game
was how to approach the whole idea of
what noir really was and I think what we
wanted to do is make sure that people
knew that no I didn't have to be black
and white and boring it was really
important to us to show that you know we
can have a fun action the kind of game
and still keep a lot of the core
elements that make more what it is we
played a lot of starfox we've got a lot
of really big fans of Rogue Squadron
yeah the rogue squadron we really want
love the intensity that that feeling you
got you know sweaty palms holding the
controller is trying to white-knuckle it
through the through the mission which
you really can't experience until you
pick up the controller
and that's really what's so special
about our game is that we've looked at
all these old classic games that meant
so much to us and did our best to really
combine all the favorite elements from
these games into just one big huge
experience and that's it looks like
we've saved the day the ship Depot is
intact
just barely smoking there and how is
gonna head on back to his garage to
collect on the bounty all right guys
thanks for watching this sneak peek at a
side mission from space Noir and
hopefully you guys are excited to see
more of what we're working on soon